i want to talk about one of my favorite
guys growing up
dion sanders hey dog you ain't that
young okay like growing up
are you a grown ass man when deion
sanders was at florida state with a
jerry curl
i want to talk about one of my favorite
guys growing up say bro you
come on now i mean you look great you
look you take good care of yourself
black dog cracking all that you look
fantastic appreciate what i mean come on
man like
my favorite i love you man like like our
favorite guys growing up
i had this football card you were
probably covering his games
anyway hey listen ain't no secrets ain't
no secrets here like i was trying to
tell
gary washburn like i tried to tell you
no secrets
uh yeah i was 19 when he was drafted he
was drafted in like 1989 right
i was 19 when i was attracted so yeah
that's right i was kind of like
i wasn't paying my own bills not not
exactly fair enough
i would say entertaining guy and the
reports are out there
and not you know we don't have anything
definitive right now
but there are some reports that he's in
negotiations to be the head coach at
jackson state
hbcu shout out uh jackson mississippi
so dion sanders the recruiter dion the
recruiter can you imagine
deion sanders says hey coach jackson
state i think this is a win for him
i think it's a win for the program i
think it could be game changing now if
i'm not mistaken
didn't sweetness go to jackson state
walter payton
now i know it was a different era a
different era of college football
especially in the 60s and 70s where you
had a lot of
hbcu athletes going to the nfl
and that's before the sec took a long
time to integrate
but once once people recognized and got
past
some of their tendencies and brought in
black athletes you saw fewer and fewer
you know elite first round picks going
to hbcus but i think that could return
with dion sanders as a head coach what
do you think i mean i'll start with
where you started with the recruiter
i mean i can't imagine a player
and or their families many of whom like
you
will have grown up or you know watched
deion sanders
when he was neon dion and he was you
know coming out of florida state you
know like i grew up a florida state fan
by the way i grew up in new orleans but
i was a florida state fan so whether it
was
real quick real how'd that happen man
yeah oh it's all right
so i remember when they were going
against miami every year
and they will always have you know wide
right i just gravitated toward bobby
bowden in fsu
and so it was like warrick dunn amply
casey weldon bar
none terrell buckley you know the whole
group dion sanders obviously
and it's funny i think i still know the
words in the notre dame fight song
because
i made a bet with a graduate of notre
dame at 93 game
i think they were both undefeated in
south bend uh charlie ward might have
been a quarterback
not mistaken and the bet was i had to
learn a notre dame fight song so i think
i learned i might even still remember
uh but anyway um yeah i mean
if you're a parent like if my son's
playing ball my son goes to play
football
and dion sanders comes to my crib and
and does his dion thing
i'm like dawg you're going to jackson
state like because i why daddy because i
want to go to jackson state because i
want to be around dion sanders you know
deion sanders no matter what he's doing
it always like if you turn down when
he's on tv if you turn down the sound no
matter what he's doing
it almost seems like he's spitting game
it's just
he's spitting game and you're buying it
the entire time you know he's got that
smile
he's got that he's got that pop he's got
that look you just believe it
so i would love to see it i don't know
uh if this thing is close if they're
just wrapping up you know i'm curious
i'm confused so so you know what i'm
confused about
i don't know what the last thing is you
read so apparently there's an issue
between you know he's an under armour
guy jackson state's a nike school so
there's issues there
but there are reports that the school is
denying all these sources you know for
whatever that's worth or denying that
he's even so much as a candidate
don't deny it actually why are y'all
doing that
yes but that's the thing it's like if
he's it's like it's not like oh we're
denying that a deal is close you know
how
that game works he's like a deal is
close oh they're denying that a deal is
close
that means it's negotiating there are
sources denying he's a candidate
that's a big difference between he's
close to being a coach and he's not a
candidate for the job
so i don't know if somebody's playing
you know games or manipulating the media
or what
but i think what both you and i are
saying is that this would be a good
uh a good a good hire for for jackson
state okay i don't want to be
disrespectful to college coaches i don't
want to suggest that
that there's no coaching going on in
college football
but you brought up a great example i
didn't think of it until you brought it
up i was wondering why
a guy who grew up in new orleans you
know in the shadows of lsu
is is rooting for florida state i'm not
judging does it sound like i'm how's my
tone on that
no you're good that's my that's the
gospel question that's a good question i
got
i gotta tell you i know what but back
without but just to ask you a question
real quick back when i was growing up
new orleans at lsu that wasn't a thing
that wasn't that when i was growing up
but go ahead okay all right so
but you mentioned bobby bowden and one
thing you remember about bobby bowden
what was it
it just a lot of things okay he had that
he had that just that that demeanor
you know folksy good with the media but
you see him on the sideline
he had a hat on but you know what i
never saw bobby bowden wear a headset
oh he did he had a headset he did have a
headset from time to time but i get what
you're saying time to get a great staff
around him
yeah mickey got a great job as a
defensive coordinator yeah
because that's what you got to do look i
think there is coaching involved
obviously
at the highest levels you look at guys
like uh nick saban
you know when pete carroll was at usc
was doing the job you
they had their fingerprints in the
program so you can't say
it's insignificant but in college
football
recruiting is that is foundational
if you are a great recruiter if you're a
great recruiter
and an above average coach you can win a
national championship
if you're a great coach and an above
average recruiter
i don't like your chances as much so i
think it'd be a great fit for deion
sanders
well and also just be a great moment
another great moment in this
this movement that we're in this
zeitgeist if you will when you look at
you know you've got big time college
basketball players looking at hbcus you
know we have one just recently go to
howard so it'd be major
to see dion sanders go there because i
think it's no question that he's getting
a lot of a lot of top-notch talent
uh if in fact um he does go there
so what else uh what else you fired up
about
oh we got yeah we got a d i've been told
to check my dms
check my dms all right hold on let's see
i got the laptop here people be thinking
about paying attention
to you oh there it is
oh can you grouch your hair
look good play good they pay good
michael
first of all he's looking good there
number two florida said that is a good
that is a good is that prom
is that home cover album cover picture
oh
sweat type vibes going on there
you